[Music]
welcome podcast alright and we are live
welcome to the iron Lords podcast
episode number 81 and it's another
glorious Sunday we are back at the
roundtable on the Lord's Day I'm
extremely excited about a special guest
so we're gonna get right into it I want
to introduce a Lord who is not only one
of the greatest legal minds to walk the
realm but amazing follow on Twitter but
as extremely candid takes the game the
community
all those opinions may conflict with
some this Lord is always willing to
engage in healthy debate defines the
rules to the game with his outstanding
blog posts it is always willing to help
us out with this amazing hashtag tweets
that legal advice introducing the
attorney a creator of the whole law
business law firm recently voted is one
of the best lawyers in America for his
work in corporate law and the Lord who
champions star control origins as his
2018 game of the year the university of
michigan's
own making his debut into the realm of
the lord's mom made Lord
Rick Hogue how you doing sir I'm good
can I can I take you around to just wear
my Rhonda necklace you know we got a
song going and you say is that hope you
are a lord of your Rose was only right I
had to say to probably respect here at
the round table how you doing it I'm
good I appreciate that I yeah I like the
I like the sentence on may disagree with
that's been on I've only been on Twitter
for about a year and people say things
man
I love it because you what think about
hook I like is that you really you
really makes you think and he really
gets your round up if you all either
side of the fence you know say it's very
very cool to see so we gonna get the icy
King Stach Matt okay your levels is good
[Music]
attics I brought my brother from another
mother will be joining in progress but
you know we have the four horsemen a
gaming those original Lords of the room
here at the round table and of course
the most technical gaming Lord the solo
gamer who lives for the single player
selfish experience and also the sastra
Thomas mister off my profile Illuminati
and Lord patreon of the iron baked mommy
Lord sovereign are you doing sir I'm
doing fantastic this Sunday morning
doing it very very well you know fall is
in full swing games are coming out Yanks
in the playoffs you know it's a
beautiful thing it's a beautiful thing
last night I have to say I said a few
tears told daddy the omage to the
captain the Mets captain David Wright
lovable was like everything from his
daughter throwing out the first pitch to
him you know just just the way he sort
of defers to the crowd and his teammates
just an amazing dude very sad that he
you know he can't even he didn't have a
long and more prosperous career still
leaving the organization being number
one and number two in a lot of
categories which is amazing unto itself
it was really beautiful thing to see I
wish I'd tried to get tickets and but I
saw the press conference late so by haim
I went to buy tickets it was sold out
and that place was packed it looked like
game 7 of the World Series me it was
really a I want to jump in on that
you guys am f eh you don't want to hit
me Soph
because obviously that team was so
talented were young in it to see ray
isn't him together on that side of the
infield and it just brought back the
feel like that was supposed to be the
future for them the only they only got
to the World Series one they won one
penny and it was just like oh you know
but he was cool too is he was so happy
he was happy to get on that field so sad
played the whole game though I know they
had a range only for a couple of innings
in a couple of bats but in the whole
game real quick when I'm playing
horizon oh well I got the I didn't get
the ultimate version I loved Forza
horizon 1 I'm not a car junkie like that
to pay 100 bucks for it so I went out I
went to my local mom-and-pop store and I
went to some place that your did you
like that should now be disclosed with
legal representation through Lara Croft
in the bush I'm just not talking anybody
that for is the man like a new bar set
for open road racing games like the
truth in the bushes like yes one of my
biggest disappointments of the year crew
- I really enjoyed the first crew that
not so much the sequel but the concept
was they just haven't they they needed
they need to hit it out of the park with
the concept they hadn't really done it
but let me ask you this because now what
cuz I haven't picked it up yet I'm el
cheapo right
Destiny's taken my life so my question
to you solve is is it
have you tried both moles cuz apparently
it was it like a performance Mosley 60
frames-per-second moon as well as a
alright like HDR mode 4k I tried both
modes during the demo and what I came
away from I decided to go with 60 right
now I'll probably I play this game so
much I'll go back and forth um but I'm
playing the 60 frames per second mocha
thing for me is in other games with 60
frames per second modes they eliminate a
lot of the effects and detail so in this
mode you do you get the the resolution
downgrade but the effects is all still
there so the game still looks nearly
beautiful and then you gotta give a
shout-out to the Samsung q LEDs like the
upscaling ability of our TVs like the
game still looks absolutely phenomenal
in to the play some of the Soulcalibur
beta the game runs beautifully looks
great um they changed a lot of hand it
to me online so you know I gotta get in
there I gotta get the dojo so it looks
like my co-host with the cool most came
through the door my brother from another
mother the difficult game Conqueror and
the how of the young mommy Lord addict
how you doing sir
doing pretty good how are you guys hol
get a building which we play at it
pretty much
whoa bars I got it needs a two-hour
energy or something you don't have to
deal with it eleven o'clock stopping for
me it's raining soon
wait no you Jess now let me actually put
something together that first game and
everybody's like oh it's just wait till
next week with disappointment right back
in still enough right on cue
disappointment creep right back ends and
then the week after that disappointed
yes I said this before the podcast
started my lions have made a lot of NFL
teams feel real good about themselves
oh they beat them bad but I thank you I
appreciate that I appreciate that from
the bottom of my heart
maybe Matt Patricia has some real
deep-seated feelings about the Patriots
and he's going to lose for the rest of
the division and just beat to beat the
patient no that is it your deck and of
course we have the Incredible Hulk of
this aka the XS gamer mm the lord of
combat sports who is a man of his
convictions demands nothing less than
that premium experience it is the leader
of the fraud alert movement Oh beloved
Lord King how you doing sir oh my god
had to wake this dude right yo I got a
good hour let me just lay down let me
just get some sleep and I'm
it wasn't an hour it was 30 minutes bro
bro I fell asleep watching the Kavanagh
stuff and that that's that's the most
hilarious stuff television can give you
if you want if you want to be in from
what listening watching Lord hogs tweet
online if you really would have beat
know you know what I try to stay away
from the whole political world I really
actually do I really try to stay away
from it but I've never seen an
individual not answer a question in so
many ways sorry I said guilty and not
guilty I really don't care but I said
that man has the art of the dodge like
his dodge but like he is constantly
hitting the X button or the Juke button
alright right now I've been playing
destiny non-stop and I've fell back on
helping anyone look at Lord addict found
out the other day is he hits like okay
yo you want to do this escalation
protocol I said no sir that'll be a no I
need the shotgun I said oh yeah I need
to level there's other people in this
planet is almost 600 if not 600 you know
599 597 stuff like that and um Here I am
with my three characters sitting at 565
I am sorry I can't I don't know how
that's fun okay lower King I just went
to loc like all we do I would outside
the clam like I said with a heavy heart
I had to tell you know and you know most
of the time I tell you yes for
everything so I do apologize and I'm
calling with fraud or myself it's like I
will call court on a lot of the next run
after us collation protocol no no raid
completions yet
Noatak did it
tack got you tack tack tack to leave the
squad and go get it done I mean because
listen this rate is a whole lot
different than the last rate now you
know this rate holds you accountable but
brother
it holds you accountable to such a level
they have the most crappiest minutia
that's put inside of it that you have to
do this one picture will everybody know
the picture room the older joint that
come on man I'm like come on tiny don't
scale
it's disgusting absolutely disgusting
but it's worth it though the drops is
worth it if you can get a good team in
there to get it done we had Chris our
past and shout out to Lord Krishna Lord
Krishna did law Tech did it and we're
supposed to do it again this weekend and
get it done with the team picture room
we was in that Lord City story using the
last picture of like 50 seconds all
right let's take our time since I jump
on them real quick Lord Attica cavity
chat says um that he needs attic to
return halo wars I'd never seen my dude
on there anymore
so what's a halo wars needs to fix Halo
Wars just in a bad place
gotcha okay so of course we got
kidnapped the way oh yeah of course it's
me the gaming ninja himself this
shouldn't ob Lord Cognito so breaking
that realness in the realm of the ILP
not telling you what you want to hear
but what you need to hear so similar to
the Lord's yeah just for me as I've been
playing you know destiny to definitely
taken up my life I had to take a break
y'all actually spoke the boxis about
this I've been suffering from sleep
deprivation because it just game and
it's not good it's not good this is not
good for my health so I had to give me a
like a two day sabbatical and actually I
broke I broke that protocol extra to
because you know what I did kick I had
to go and log into spider so I get those
nasty what cause for the cheat before I
reset so they're fixing that they take a
master workhorse out of the game the
economy is real tough for its usual
wait yeah the way you're doing it is
over there taking the master workhorse
out I had over 100 and master word cause
and I'm down to three
yeah it's bad I mean khakis had a funny
tweet where he had a veto brown and put
the gun to his president it is like he
said when you when you had your best
destiny gun from year one but you add a
master what they're doing is they're
replacing it basically yeah they
renaming it something else and then
they're also making the option to get
them a little bit more easy yeah if you
made it to where you know first off you
can make it to her spider you know it's
a little bit more flexible and I just
laid a right or you can make it to her
because there's ten levels and you need
it for everything about three right just
makes it like the last three you require
master cord they're doing a lot man you
gotta watch the flashpoint list with me
any bonds is broken down they're saying
that they understand the problem those
resources cuz I ain't about that life
hold on let me let me say one thing
before we start the show um I'm going to
do a combat talk and I can be about any
fights because there was no fighters
particularly good at fighting rights
week and it was crappy face this weekend
but it's going to be on the death of HBO
boxing yeah it's it's a pretty sad thing
but it's very intricate and how we got
from point A to point B as clear as
people may think it is as they you know
just either got the butt whipped by this
person and just was like you know what
I'm done
no it was a slow descent into exactly
where they're at at the bottom so it
used to be the cram yeah yeah yeah look
out for misters days Larry Burchett Jim
Lampley all that good stuff so and Roy
with the green mic where I take that
combat talk because
this is definitely gonna touch and it's
gonna poke a lot of nerves um but I'm
gonna have to tell it like it is and
some people may not like one hair look
forward to it but yeah but other than
that for me um I got a shout out man my
guys from weapon studios and THQ Nordic
this is the police
part return oh I want to give that game
a shout-out like I didn't I played a
little bit of the first one but I didn't
really cuz uh I had it for the Xbox and
I had it for the switch and I didn't
really like dive dive into it but like I
guess the XCOM things i got me in a
little bit more but like some of the the
dialogue in the game is I'm just like I
was reading it to kids smooth like
literally there's a there's a there's
literally a time where someone's like if
someone is true you know they're they're
talking about all kinds of really dark
stuff and it's and you have an option to
say good I don't got time for yourself
either jump yes like so jaqobis Alyssa
the the police calls did you respond to
and the scenarios load home that you
have to deal with this game was the most
not suitable for work I am shocked at
his on a Nintendo platform like to be
honest like I've said this with the
first one the second one is gonna shout
out they got the voice actor from Duke
Nukem he's back which was the main
character Jack point he's kind of more
in a supplementary role this time
there's a female police chief there is
anti-feminist stuff going on in his gate
like this game touches all subjects if
you feel a way about certain subjects or
groups this game attacks it there
there's no filter and all type of
corruption debauchery the game is
hilarious it's a little bit of XCOM and
for our tactical when you go on the
scene but prior to that it's really
well-written you have a lot of dialogue
in between and it's people management
you have to manage your cops
you have to man they get tired guys or
make up excuses every day to come up and
work it is so much it's fun funny I'm
back in my zone so I'm warning the Lords
now during the week late night my tweets
might be not suitable for because I'll
be screen
take somebody's stuff it's funny oh I
actually convinced someone to buy it
they're like is it worth $30 I was like
I'm not I'm only like two hours into it
I could tell you this guy's over $30 I
know for a fact it's got replay value no
they're so let's get it to it maybe I
like to talk about in this show so now
we got into with the Lord's a plan I
want to start off with Lord hope his
video game system history his initial
legal journey an adventure creation of
Hogg law business law firm and of course
would let him to become the leader of
the help us out hold in tweets not
equally so lord please actually rig
stuff for the beginning what was some of
the video game systems you had and what
got you a game oh man well I like so
many people my my father was a big
techie back in the 70s and so the first
thing that I can remember is is really
old I mean we had an in television we
had we had an Atari 2600 and that really
graduated into an Atari ST a Commodore
64 into NES at the end of the 80s and
then on the PC side with Ataris
ultimately with a lot of Macintoshes at
the time so we had we had an old Mac
that overheated at the top so we had to
pay for chimney that on top of the
Macintosh to keep it to keep its heat
down and I remember a lot of good games
on those I used to play the adventure
type games and yeah it was that that
love really came from my father in all
honesty you know and as that period went
on obviously Super Nintendo Sega Genesis
but even the more expensive niche stuff
we got a chance to play so we had a
turbo graphics CD we had a 3do and and
that love just permeated my life
honestly you know I really was a
defender of videogames even in the the
nerd classes in middle school in high
school on debate and on quizzes and you
know this is how I learned a lot of
vocabulary was from Final Fantasy 6 and
I learned quest
and I thinking about economics and
developing my you know political and
economic philosophies from playing
civilization and sid meier's alpha
centauri playing games like arrow biz on
the Super Nintendo and and I've
maintained that love throughout so I I
went to Michigan law school from 2002 to
2005 in 2005 I get out of law school and
I'm hired by big law firm in Ann Arbor
so right there near the law school
homepage and I start out doing venture
capital and and mergers and acquisitions
and I don't want to bore your listeners
we can talk about the details on any of
that as much as you want or as little as
you want but I did that for a long
period of time and then 2008 rolls
around and as you might remember a lot
of stuff slowed down including venture
capital in Michigan and like a lot of
employers they say alright that's good
but what are you doing to make sure that
you keep your plate full what do you
mean what are you doing to make sure
we're keeping the revenues out good and
so I said well you know I have a deep
love for for games and technology and
Ann Arbor is a big hot spot for
development and new new inventions ideas
biopharmaceuticals life sciences and I
said let's start to do more software
stuff and we had a kind of small
burgeoning software field at Hana Glenn
Miller Schwartz and cone which is the
big loss which is wishing you to give a
home base first that's what you started
yeah that was that was where it started
and I worked on software and at that
point in time software as a service was
very novel in terms of what legal
documentation was behind it it still is
frankly and so I put it upon myself to
go learn how to do those documents how
to negotiate those licenses and electro
property and as we went on from there a
lot of the big clients that law firm had
custom software development needs so I
had those connections I made those
connections and ultimately the venture
capital came back mergers and
acquisitions came back and on top of
that I had this burgeoning software
practice nice so from there I decided I
wanted to be an equity partner senior
partner
wouldn't that the highest-level at the
law firm so I made that my goal in 2014
going up the ladder let's go ladder 2014
I I made that happen got that got voted
up as an equity partner ironically on
the same day that Harbaugh was flying in
to give his press conference the
University of Michigan's these things
you know stick in your memory as soon as
I got that I said hey you know what's
next and I looked at it and I said I
want to run my own place so I talked
with some partners and I and I talked
about what that might look like and in
April of 2016 so not that long ago but
long enough that I'm happy to say I can
still feed the family we created the new
law firm 2016 was making sure that we
could do it
2017 was really kind of moving forward
with what this what it looks like to
market this thing and so that was when I
initially connected with folks like the
easy allies it's when I started my
Twitter really on the notion that a lot
of people could use good legal advice
and a lot of people are kind of
standoffish about what a lawyer is
especially transactional lawyer you know
one of the things I say on my my tweets
one of the things I say my emails
weren't things I say on my phone calls
is I'm not a law-and-order guy I'm not
the guy that goes from stands in front
of the court and says objection
overruled and so what do I do and
communicating the people and you know
I've come up with ways to say hey look
you know if you're signing your name to
something that's when you should really
think about maybe getting somebody to
read that something for you and whether
that's a lease whether that's a custom
contract whether that's a consulting
agreement or services arrangement you
know maybe we can make that work I know
that lawyers are a cost center but the
thing I tell my clients is in general
I've helped people to start out with and
I fixed a lot of problems in fixing the
problems costs five times as much and so
you can have that call with me to start
out with if we can get you to a place
where we say hey that provision is
terrible let's cross that out regardless
of whether they say it's not negotiable
everything's negotiable we can have that
conversation and I feel like I can get
that value added to folks that are
starting up
maybe haven't done this before and and
folks that maybe just don't know what
they're signing up for you know I mean
the story I'd like to give to folks is I
had a client that signed a waste
management contract just folks that come
and pick up the trash yes and they
needed to move locations they were
growing they were expanding they were a
big successful company they were moving
to a different spot and this waste
management contract said that's fine you
can get out of this contract because we
don't service that new location but
it'll cost nineteen thousand dollars
does you do and they call me up and they
say you know it's $50 a month what's
what's the deal here and I take a look
at the contract this is after the fact I
didn't look at it beforehand and I say
well they've got a provision here that
says you owe them triple for every month
on what would have remained under the
contract and you signed a 15-year waste
management contract so you know we can
negotiate and say but once you owe them
that money you're not in a position to
leverage exactly and so I I feel like I
can give value to folks that want to do
good things want to have good ideas want
to be out there and making our lives all
of our lives better by whatever idea
they want to bring to fruition and I can
do it in a bit in a way that's I
hesitate to exactly use the word fun but
approachable okay people and they can
make jokes about Urban Meyer's history
of lying which I see your timeline very
good kind of conversational points about
what the law is what they should be
looking out for and then yeah live-tweet
nine hours of the Cavanaugh hearings you
job so it Egypt oh my god so much your
job the other thing I want to get but
let's go back to the game for a second a
second and I just want to say like okay
first of all shout out to the dads out
there cuz your history kind of similar
to mine my dad was kind of the one that
was a techie to kind of introduce me to
gaming so you did say Atari 2600 yeah
did say tell you drop some bomb names
and you even said the niche stuff which
is like turbo graphics 16 CD which King
would I know
illegal now it was clear my god addict
we were talking before his time but like
I noticed you mentioned when I wanted to
ask you about NES the original NES
yeah the ones having any gaps in Nano
did you experience those well no I had
an NES I that was my first introduction
to Final Fantasy which would be a life
and I still vividly remember speaking my
father one of the few times we really
needed help on a game and you know game
facts the internet didn't exist back
then right bragging warrior the original
Dragon Warrior which was Dragon Quest in
Japan of course had a quest about
two-thirds of the way through we had to
find something called the Sunstone and
the trick to finding this thing was that
the the towns in Dragon Warrior would
immediately pop you out to the world map
when you left except that one town
didn't do that and so you had to notice
that if you could go two squares past
the entrance point and walk around the
outside wall and there was the Sun stone
my dad and I could not figure this out
to save our lives in the time that I
remember that we called the Nintendo
helpline that was a minute some crazy
and they it was very funny because you
can tell when it's one of those areas
where clearly people were getting hung
up because the guy basically said
Sunstone and the but I remember that
vividly obviously that's a great memory
for me working through these issues with
my father
yeah and the original NES that the Hogue
family had a game princess tomato and
the vegetable kingdom I think that we
would play and we weren't allowed to
play on our own that we would play after
dinner as a family well of course
because I I'm obviously a rebel and a
renegade I pulled a little forward in
princess tomato one day and I got I got
punished I got grounded I said families
that's that's a breach of the family
trust tomato life lessons but I love it
value said the [ __ ] stuff you've
mentioned also are 3d oh I watch
expression we have to we have a lot of
three do fish out do a lord bills still
well lawful marks or back compatibility
team as well as uh Lord John Lennon min
and we have a bunch of three do face so
tell us about your experience about the
Panasonic interactive real player
remember that I love the 3do so as you
as you said in my introduction one of
the things I'm really excited about
right now is start control origins and
my my favorite game of all time is a
game called star control - mmm place
where I was introduced to that game was
on the was on the 3do and and I played
that game at this point in time playing
it now and emulated for him on the PC
I've probably played that game two dozen
times yes and and that is absolutely
fantastic the 3do like the turbo
graphics CD like the CDI at that point
in time in the 90s where some of the
only places where you could really get
really good at the time full motion
video sound orchestration yeah it's just
blew us away
I remember sitting there again with my
father and my brother playing east book
one and two on the on the turbo graphics
and having these anime cutscenes start
out the game with this rock music music
was incredible but I just heard you say
Philip CD I did you play that crappy
Zelda I did my parents on that Zelda I
played that Zelda CDI you know we got
that primarily for at I think it launch
of that system there was a golf game and
the golf game had essentially treatment
of the golfing like it was on TV they
had the announcers for really the first
kind of very significant announcing they
had full motion video golfers kind of
putting and then Saku just miss that one
yeah
my dad absolutely adored that you know
that was the biggest deal they had
little Chiron's that came up that showed
it exactly like on TV and and we were
just in love with that so that's I don't
have as many memories of the CDI as I do
the 3do 3do I was playing road rash
video I really loved it had kind of
warriors but yeah star control on the
3do there was a was a game show game
called twisted that I played what about
we you've talked about this until what
about alone in the dock did you have a
good 3do version I played a my
recollection as I played alone on the
dark on the PC okay okay
but I loved alone in the dark that's
obviously the predecessor really - what
Resident Evil took over for Talk That
Talk good time that's one of those where
it's yes this is a good idea maybe not
fully realized Resident Evil in and says
let's throw some money at it and you
know Resident Evil's is is the classic
though I think it's always interesting
to pull those threads apart and take a
look at where the ideas came from
because video gaming is still so
terribly young compared to most
industries that we would otherwise talk
about or look at and so you can still
see well here's how we solved for
first-person shooters and consoles and
here's the great idea that Halo had and
here's a great idea to call you be
strapped on to it and here's what alone
in the dark did and here's what Resident
Evil did and and here's how we got from
X to Y and I think that's so cool and I
still have a great deal of fun looking
at those things I do think that as we've
kind of promoted high textures and big
expensive things we've lost some of that
nuance and kind of interesting game
design at kind of a higher levels than
doublea's maybe if not the triple A's
and but I like playing that the indie
games and some of the other kind of
independent developers takes on these
things because I love them but I don't
want everything to be a first-person
shooter or a third-person agreed agreed
agreed and shout out to the Chapman say
oh he's a shout out to teach people Nord
in order for purchasing the
in the dark IP a lot of alone in the
dark fans a lot of people loving these
memories you're talking about Laurel um
but I want to ask you I know you glanced
over as far as a lot of our chat in our
Lord's they know you from easy allies
they helped us out whole series so I
know you did briefly touch on it but
like how did that link-up really coming
under could be and then also I want to
shout out a lot Brandon Jones Kyle
Boltzmann and those guys they they do a
fantastic job so like how did that
happen where you now are added into like
a gaming vodcast to be asked legal
advice about you know how things work
how did that whole thing really I'm
gonna be well as you know easy allies is
patreon supported and they had a podcast
sponsorship open up in February of 2017
when I was looking at I've got this
budget of marketing and how do I want to
spend it yeah and one of the things that
I really liked about them in particular
and I told this to them is their focus
on being positive not to the exclusion
of everything else but really on a focus
on what you know what can we take as a
silver lining what can we take about
positivity here primarily because a lot
of the the games media in my experience
reading them launching them has kind of
developed a certain level of cynical
ironic snark fine but I'm a I tend to be
a more earnest guy you can tell from
these discussions of my my past I love
this stuff at a kind of very fundamental
level and the easy allies really spoke
to me in the way that they were talking
about things nicely and then a friend of
mine forwarded to me the trial of Kyle
Bosman where instead of just being a
comedy skit they actually had I don't
know if you remember this video or saw
this either they had Bloodworth they had
some other folks come out and actually
talk about things like good faith and
fair dealing in contract terms and
whether there was proper contract
negotiation and language in there and
then they these were my people they were
they were English and technical in a way
that I really enjoyed that all right
let's put some money down and that's us
that's us and I've gotten clients from
that sponsorship Wow
I've obviously gotten to know some of
the guys and I think sometime in July of
last year there was some stuff happening
there were some studio closures there
was a visceral there was an EI dealing
with some things and I had tweeted out
and I tweeted to Kyle and I think to
Brandon and that well you know some of
this is being motivated by corporate
structuring that we're looking at games
as a service making so much more money
than single player and he always jumps
on this life raft and some of this is
about fiduciary duties which is now
catchphrase over it easy allies but do
you want to talk about that at all and
and I all said yeah let's let's talk
about fan games let's talk about
fiduciary duties let's do that yeah
eventually you know when I was that when
when they asked me questions and I was
submitting stuff for the fifth time the
sixth time the seventh time that just
became a thing that people liked and
then Kyle emailed me and said you know
they were getting a lot of positive
feedback about those segments and did I
want to do more and there might be some
stuff in the offing a very busy guy so
they were always coming up with new
stuff but there there should be
potentially something on the horizon for
that okay alright so Natalie was a
helpless out ho born we got more stuff
cooking you know who knows that could be
three years down the pipe but yes it is
fair to say we've got stuff cooking
I salute to easy allies and it's got a
fantastic job so well yeah man that you
love another catch phrase for you guys
for your firm in particular obviously a
big firm loyal with small firm approach
yeah so for us laymen
legal Lords right what's the difference
between like the big firm versus small
firm mentality and then I want you to
also if you can tie in what aspects you
have the impact what aspects of the
legal side of the gaming industry that
made me gamers don't truly understand so
two question sure well I mean I think
that the big firm lawyer comes from my
background you know when as part of
marketing as part of telling people hey
yes I'm a guy that uses you know virtual
services and and uses virtual networking
and can take my laptop around and so I
don't necessarily have
the hardwood floors in the fancy office
and the and the hundred-person
secretarial staff but that you're not
going to get a lesser service for that I
was trained there I went to a top ten
law school I graduated at the top one
percent of my class talk about it worked
there for thirteen years I learned
mergers and acquisitions venture capital
I have all the pieces that you need that
being said if you're concerned about
being treated as a number or being
treated in a way that hey if I can only
pay you ten thousand dollars instead of
a hundred thousand dollars you're gonna
treat me less than and I'm not gonna
happen here respect i I I'm focused like
Jerry Maguire in the first act not fewer
clients less money personal service
let's get you to a place where you're
getting the legal service you need and
not breaking the bank and not scuttling
the ship while you're trying to launch
it no that's what I mean by big firm
lawyers small firm approach yes I'm
gonna know your name we're gonna have
in-depth talks I meet with clients for
coffee they not build we just talk for
an hour and have those conversations and
get them to a place where they feel
comfortable in the business side of
things with the legal contracts where
they wouldn't otherwise feel comfortable
because I'm talking to geniuses you know
I'm talking to neuroscientists and
rocket scientists and people developing
cures for cancer and things like that
but they don't know how a capitalization
table works or what your shareholding
should look like or what a pre-money
valuation is compared to a series a
liquidation preference and I can give
that to them and try not to break the
bank while we do that that was some very
honorable lord howe respected now and
and i think in your introduction you
kind of hinted at it which is you know I
have people on Twitter or people on
Google calling me a corporatist or
capitalist scum no I mean you can so
what I try to do is I try to go out
there and say all right so this thing is
happening Telltale's closing Viceroy's
closing x y&z is happening with
contracts here's what it means when THQ
nordic buys a Millar out of a banker's
bankruptcy estate to try to give people
a
little bit more factual understanding of
the structure behind gaming industry or
any other industry you want to talk
about so that yeah you can be mad about
things that are deserving of being mad
about but maybe not as mad about things
that are kind of natural and the way
these things probably have to play out
structurally so I'm not trying to take
away anybody saying telltale treated
those people wrongly for instance I am
trying to explain what it means to be
insolvent what it means to not have
enough money to pay the creditors you
have a contractual relationship with and
what kind of box the telltale management
was in under the under the rules of law
and you could say Rick those laws are
stupid now I could say okay we can have
that but let's have that conversation
and not jump immediately to your evil
capitalist swine that we need out behind
pictures on NASA I don't mind it I like
having these conversations I like my
wife gets upset at Twitter because she
doesn't like people being mean to me and
I'm sorry I got a throw Atika to the bus
because he represents the youngest Lord
on the pad and I love anything about her
he represents back I don't say he always
votes on the side of the consumer and
doesn't understand the corporation side
at oh I'm not say that but there's some
time he definitely immediately assumes
that it's some evil thing going on okay
like I said you wouldn't be the first
person to call me an evil corporate
swine but but that's really when when we
talk about help us out Hogan easy allies
when we talk about my twitter feed at
home ah by the way it's one of those
things where I have this background I
have this edge
occasion and this experience and I just
want to talk about that I'm not trying
to put judgments on how anybody feels
about anything other than to say hey if
you feel this way for this reason and
that reason maybe isn't true or doesn't
exist let's talk about that because
let's get it to I can see this where we
talk about the Cavanaugh hearings for
two hours a good friend to though to the
round team is gonna show all of the
MPD's Oh Lord Matt piscatella and what I
yes yes so pretty much you know I
remember this was a wild bagging you
guys have had some interesting Twitter
banter I feel back and forth over the
years so one of the conversations I want
to focus on particularly that caught my
attention was like the whole terminology
of game developer do you remember this
conversation yes if not I could refresh
basically what I recall was um there was
a gentleman I'm not gonna name his name
he's on Twitter and you know pretty much
he made a statement that said like
people that are game to that death so
he's like designer artist programmer you
know HR community managers etc he had a
long list and Dom I believe you chimed
in and then you basically with basically
use like you know look everyone that
puts work into something you know and I
quote you said it Joyce deserves they
deserve credit absolutely he said that
said words must convey meaning to be
useful and no one intends to refer to HR
business development marketing or
cafeteria staff when using the term
developer then I believe about
piscatella jumped in and he said look
you know an independent game developer
must write program QA market etc and yet
they still call themselves des and then
I felt you had the funniest comeback of
the night you said sure anyone that
directly develops a game rather than
infrastructure is a developer regardless
of whether they also sweep the floors
but if your only role is sweeping the
floors yes you help facilitate the
game's creation but you
didn't in any real way development in
you to go back and forth but then you
kind of came to resolution but I just
wanted to ask you about early an
argument oh I was just tuning in because
these are my guys I like hope I like
whiskey teller and I've seen a couple
tests go so I just wanted to clarify
that your whole position on developer
not to be big beef but just the whole
well you know the one thing I never
quite got on this was you know it was it
was Ram II from Vlambeer comes out and
says this that all these people are game
developers I feel I still feel like
something precipitated that I wasn't
part of that conversation right though I
do still feel like I stepped into some
kind of discussion
probably about unionization or something
along those lines you are currently was
Rabi but yeah my position is you can't
just say an independent game developer
does all these things and you can't take
that away because they do these other
things that's absolutely true my brother
and I you know did I phone apps for a
couple years that I'm very proud of and
that's everything you do everything
involved with that process but part of
that is you did the writing in the
programming and the developing of the
game as well as figuring out how to keep
the lights on and and and you know
dusting the place my point was that if
we're going to talk about who a game
developer is we just need to be careful
that we're not including people that are
useful to of any corporate structure but
not in particular the development of the
game and and somebody I think came on
later and said well we usually refer to
it as companies and that's that's true
that's fine
when you say X company is a developer I
have no problem with that
but if you say somebody the really the
closest gray area for me personally is
when you talk about HR at a major
software house they're mostly and
they're mostly hiring and firing and
coordinating disputes did that person
develop product X and I would say no for
the most part and I think that might be
where we have a disagreement
I don't mind mad at all Matt comes hard
and he likes to be very strident you
know what he said
I got no problem with that because I
like to do that to know that it was cool
and like I said one thing about you guys
and Matt doubled down on his day he just
he just wanted to I wanted to protect in
a sense that you know he just was
talking about far as gatekeeping the
term and one thing that I like that you
guys even though you may bump hey you
guys do come to kind of like a
reasonable understanding so that you
know even if you still on that side of
the fence it's it's respectable yeah I
do like that about you too you guys can
have respectable disagreements so I
thought I just thought that was I
remember it like the back of my hand and
I was like wow that's funny this is a
let it go it started this you started
that and I thought for sure you were
gonna pull up some of my polygon or
katana I wouldn't do that you actually
specialize in and I hope laws obviously
which affirm its mergers and
acquisitions right yeah right so with
the recent studio acquisitions by
Microsoft me you know think they were
quite undead labs yes you theory and now
the rumors of another Microsoft a
cuisine being revealed at this newly
announced possibly River this newly
announced EXO 18 phantomon I wanted your
input on the process of how like gaming
acquisitions get done or just the input
on the length of time to complete
you see Microsoft just I called the
Infinity Gauntlet moment they just
snatching up all the gems and like how
is this going like how far is the time
just give us some input on how that
whole processes sure
well my part of that's gonna depend on
whether the company is shopping itself
or whether it just gets a call out of
the blue mm-hmm so a lot of my clients
essentially decide they look at their
numbers they look at what it takes to
grow it looks they look at where their
current lives are and say hey I think
we'd like to figure out what this thing
might might get us if we if we sold it
right now right who's they okay let's
look at what a term sheet would look
like in a term sheet is a shorter
document between one and ten pages that
says here's what this sale will look
like and let's talk to people about
whether that's attractive and what that
number should be that top line X million
dollars and see if there's anybody
that's biting I just finished the sale
of a company this last week that
that was the process give you some kind
of context of what the timing for that
was we went out with term sheets in
about May and I said we closed last week
so this is so this is a process you're
talking with the junior bow and I'm up
stakes time well that's why Microsoft
couldn't say the other Studios these
they talked about only the studios that
the ink was dry on and it was other
studios that they're in acquisitions and
conversations about they can't talk
about and that ink dry is interesting so
there's two ways to essentially close
these deals you can close them as a sign
and close meaning when daddy dries when
you sign that document the company is
yours or you can sign them as a sign and
then close which is you look at like the
Disney Foxx acquisition Brock's is not
owned by Disney right this second right
they've announced it they signed the
deal it's been approved by the
shareholders it's done except for when
you sign and then closed there's a list
of things that have to happen the
government has to approve X our
third-party contractors have to approve
the assignment of the contracts if
that's what's happening in the deal we
need to get approval from X board why
board and Z board and and so you have
this process where you've got Fox and
Disney signed up to something and I my
bet would be that they will close that
deal sometime in the first or second
quarter next year because with that
sense you brought up that exactly that -
oh okay I just saw that Disney and Fox
agreed to sell comcast sky network this
guy yeah right so in the whole big
structure Disney actually was going
after Fox because of the assets that
they had in sky network right yeah I was
sold the Fox assets as entertainment and
news and Disney wasn't as interested in
the news side they would have they would
have been fine Disney's a megalith and
would buy everything they could if they
want you know if they were able to but
they that wasn't what was driving the
value proposition for them they're still
basically funding the content creation
for Disney streaming though so what what
happened is
went in I believe Comcast and Fox Fox
still being its own shell bid on the
remainder of sky that was an auction
that happened either let this last week
or two weeks ago and Fox lost as they
were always going to because Comcast had
this big pile of money that they didn't
spend buying Fox the 40 million bought
the remained over 40 billion yeah
Comcast bought the remainder of sky and
then they probably did that with phone
calls and an understanding that because
neither Disney nor Comcast wants half of
sky or whatever those percentages were
that Disney would have Fox sell the
remainder to Comcast and they'd
essentially bifurcate completely so but
you see in that kind of relationship
that Disney is still essentially making
those decisions running Fox and Fox's
saying okay since we're gonna be part of
the Disney family we can give up this
sky piece to Comcast and Comcast can
have this whole asset so that they're
happy now now this is my question right
now seeing that happen who does the 40
billion go to because if like you said
they're waiting for the hack use it the
the you know the the X's and O's to be
checked off on the boxes for the Fox
team to go through like you know the
government and everything saying that's
okay the question is where did that who
does the 40 billion go to with the
acquisitions of sky because actually
being purchase bought from Fox right but
Disney actually owns Fox now so that's
what that was they don't own Fox now
they have a signed deal to own Fox right
what will happen is Fox will take this
asset and they will exchange it for a
sack of money that is 40 billion dollars
and then they will and then the
shareholders will have that asset and
then it depends on what the asset I'm
sorry what the stock purchase agreement
between Fox and Disney says so there
could be an adjustment for excess of
cash that would otherwise be sitting in
the company or there could be some kind
of dispersal mechanism that would have
that money go out to the existing Fox
shareholders before they sell probably
not that because the Disney Fox sales
price is already set right you're gonna
buy Fox at this set sail
price and now included a sky asset that
has been essentially converted into a
sack of money so chances are they can't
distribute that but I don't want to say
for sure because that would be part of
the agreement
Roka gotcha actually all I want to get
into the chat because uh Lord Sam
Tolbert had a fantastic question he said
up he Lord Hawk he said at what point
does a video game studio acquisition is
a letter of intent filed and can you
break that process down sure so a letter
of intent for not just a video game
company but anybody else is is largely a
non-binding document what a letter of
intent says is here is how the
definitive agreements will look and the
reason we do this process is so that we
can agree on the major issues that if we
didn't have agreement on we shouldn't
pay the lawyers 50 grand to draft these
documents so a letter of intent will say
the top line price is 50 million dollars
here are the employees that we're going
to hire after the acquisition takes
place here is the bonus plan that
they're gonna have here are the promises
that you have to make about the company
when we buy it and here's how the
documentation is going to look that's a
very short way of describing it but
that's what what happens and then what's
a binding part of the letter of intent
is generally exclusivity and
confidentiality so you have a letter of
intent here's our top-line stuff once
you sign this the lawyers can get going
it's non-binding we haven't sold you the
company yet until we have these
definitive documents but what is binding
is you won't tell anybody about what
these terms are and you won't try to
sell the company out from under us to
someone else during a 60 day period from
after when we signed this so that letter
of intent doesn't get filed it doesn't
go to a state agency it doesn't do any
of those things what it is a contract it
binds you to be quiet about it and to
not talk to other people so when you see
sometimes things get leaked out where
somebody has cut off discussions they
were discussing with a bunch of people
and they've cut off three of them
sometimes the business journalist says
we think they signed a letter of intent
with X and and that can happen so that's
really the letter of intent process it's
the first step to say we are
in principle to selling you the company
for X amount of dollars and now we can
pay the lawyers they're obviously
exorbitant fees to document this thing
and and we would we don't feel too bad
about it that's really what a term sheet
is though it's pretty much like opening
negotiations and you're gonna be talking
to me if you side this no one else right
so yes so the the letter of intent is
really those bullet points of if all of
this works out we assume the lawyers can
sort out the rest if this if these six
bullet points are true then we're
willing to sell you the company and so
we will sign on the dotted line for
starting this process mm-hmm sounds good
I got it you got my mind going now
because um you know this exclusivity and
letter of intent and you knew exactly
lawyer talk no no Lord Cox is a huge
destiny fan and one question had always
been in the background mine was the
relationship between Sony and Activision
slash Bungie on exclusivity now we do
know that they have on you know that the
rights to the maps and uses inclusive
map exclusive exotic that's generally
how to format goals whenever a new desk
the expansion comes out or a new title
comes out now there was one specific
time where protocol I would say was kind
of broken because prior to that point
prior to the taken King right usually a
full year calendar year would go pass
and then the Xbox would be allowed to
have those exclusive items as far as DLC
is concerned right or as far as on you
know exotics or whatever the the maps
were that were exclusive to PlayStation
right I mean one time during when a ten
King launched the actual exotics didn't
come or the map didn't come to xbox and
when questioned Bungie was questioned by
it they kind of dodged it but they they
kind of said you know it's really still
up to you know Activision or Sony or
whatever they kind of dodged it so my
question to you is would conflict these
kind of agreements the exclusive
agreements and video games you know I've
never seen a situation like destinies
where the length of time is the length
of time which is a year usually content
apps are like a couple of moms maybe but
I've never seen this before
and then how is it possible if they were
able to change the nature of that
agreement when previously it was a year
is that a fluid situation that can
always be edited so this is all
speculation - it's not legal advice
let's go hashtag yeah you know
likelihood it's a continuing marketing
arrangement mmm so destiny really
Activision gets a marketing combination
with Sony so you see those Dhoni
probably pays for some of the bad spots
when the Sony Playstation Bullet thing
on at the end
destiny gets put in those Sony
Marketplace old guy commercials and and
they get to have a place at the e3 press
conference they get talked about that
kind of thing and as part and parcel to
that as a quid pro quo Activision has to
give something back
so Activision in pay cash money
Activision can make content Activision
can make that content exclusive for a
period of time and chances are the way
this works is each new piece of content
has an addendum or another agreement
where they say this is what this is what
this exclusivity will look like this is
what this is going to look like there's
about four I bet I'm forgetting the tiny
two DLCs at the beginning of destiny but
yeah dark below in House of wolves there
so for those they might have said okay
the PlayStation will have a gun the gun
will be for three months and then it'll
be on xbox or whatever that timeframe
was and then when you taking King comes
out it'll be forever it'll be for a year
or whatever it is that comes out for
every piece of content and it's really
just a matter of what I tell people is
especially commercially you can contract
for whatever you want
so if Activision wants to say we'll make
this and it'll never be on any other
system elsewise basically the way that
negotiation works is you got to make it
worth our while sony sony says all right
how about two e threes and six million
dollars worth of commercials and the
treatment
in a package with a Playstation 4 and
prominent position on our PlayStation
Store for six months
and and she just you know you'd think
about when you're playing Madden and
you're putting the sliders and trying to
get the trade negotiations just right
that's what a contract negotiation is is
is that enough no I want this too is
that enough no I want this too and it
can be anything and sometimes it's gonna
be three months sometimes that's going
to be a year sometimes that's going to
be forever
you gotta rise a Tomb Raider round where
when something is already month
multi-platinum rather than creation even
if it is eeling making it look like
creation so Sony's gotten better at
being like well we're not sure this
content would have existed without this
marketing plan and you say yeah maybe
not interesting so again just to be
clear this is in the new destiny
situation the relationship is between
Activision and Sony it is but days is
there any liability to Bungie cuz a lot
of people attack Bungie directly say you
guys or holding content are they they
not responsible so to speak is it
between those nine
I mean you we could look at the lawsuits
from way back when but in general a
publisher that has that kind of
exclusive right to publish it has an
exclusive right to market that what
you're doing is you're getting this set
amount of money to hit milestones to
develop to pay your people that's that's
Activision to Bungie and in exchange
Bungie is giving to Activision certain
rights both in royalties and in revenue
and also rights to to market the thing
as it so chooses that's why again using
the rise the Tomb Raider example when
that happened you had essentially
Crystal Dynamics say hey man we don't
know what Square Enix is doing it stop
stop texting us Wow thank you for the
clarity I've always wanted to know that
when you no good at it ever since I
didn't even really like I know I never
really thought about how they can use
III as a leverage I mean
obviously that's a set stage they have a
lot of people I never thought and that
could be a huge key that people that you
know these these platform holders can
use because there's a lot of people that
watch III and that's worth a lot of
money I mean look look what happened
with them what was the game that Sony
did the the Kickstarter thing on like
just because that was shown on the stage
it was funded before III was even over
yeah it's valuable the really
interesting thing about those kind of
relationships is oftentimes when you're
talking about contracts you've got value
running one way and you see the other
side kind of pay for it with money or
exclusivity with these with the video
game industry's one of the really
awesome and fascinating things about it
from a contract law perspective is yes
at the same time that it's useful for
destiny to be on Sony stage it's useful
for Sony to have destiny on its stage so
it's really this kind of interesting yes
you probably do owe us some money we
should figure out how to do this
exclusivity but it's not like we're not
getting a benefit from having you
exclusively on our stage so it's really
an interesting kind of back and forth
there that a good example of that would
be like CD Projekt RED with cyberpunk
right sure we want to you know show our
game but let's be real we don't need you
Microsoft we're getting something out of
this in return right and they got what
they got was an absolutely awesome
finale to that e3 show with that was
that was amazing yeah it's so
interesting to see how this stuff works
about it I think this is awesome thank
you fancies questions I'm gonna finish
up the the Q&A with the Lords if the
Lords want to jump in Louis oven and
only had questions yeah I'm you know we
talked about this last week but I would
definitely like to talk about a little
more in depth on the tell-tale stuff
yeah my I know you've had some discourse
on Twitter all over this which people
feel like you know obviously that the
informer employees need to be taken care
of above and beyond everything else and
then you you took it from the law side
how they you know explaining solvency
and and the fact that they need to they
need to take care of people that are
contractually obligated to take care of
before they even consider anything like
that but my question to you is as
somebody who
who has an interest on both ends of this
as a gamer who obviously plays these
games and wants and wants these
companies to be successful what do you
think ISM is is a middle ground for this
sort of stuff like wait what has to
happen in the gaming industry so that
these developers are taken care of and
the business side is also taken care of
and everything everyone is able to move
forward and and sort of benefit from
this it's as unionization and answer
because I know a lot of quarters of the
Internet are talking about that sort of
stuff like this needs to happen so that
closures like this don't happen how
people are taking care of people if
there are closures people have severance
things like that so as somebody who's
sort of vested on both sides what do you
think is a possible solution to this
sort of stuff well I think the starting
point for that would be to say telltale
was absolutely mismanaged you know I do
a lot of talking on Twitter and I do a
lot of talking in law with tweets not
legal advice and couching it in saying
maybe they weren't or maybe this or
perhaps that telltale was mismanaged
they took what would have been a
business model and they spent too much
money and realized not enough revenues
and and they went down even talking
about what happened in the last couple
weeks it was clear that they needed an
external financial influx in order to
keep the keep the boat floating and when
that failed they went under so starting
their day they were mismanaged in terms
of unionization and I you know I I
tweeted a little bit about this yes you
do Kotaku I think unions are absolutely
fine if you if people want to join them
I think should be clear to what they do
and what they don't do and what they
wouldn't solve is a failed business
model mmm telltale not making enough
money on what it sells would not have
lasted longer or been better off by
increasing its labor costs by 30% or 50%
or whatever and I think that's clear
enough when I say it like that
what you see in the tweet response what
you see in the internet response is is
well maybe these folks shouldn't have
had that job then if they're not getting
severance and they're working these long
hours and they would have been better
off if telltale did go under two years
ago or if they would have had a deal
with this Union and I can't tell them
they're wrong right what I can tell them
from my perspective is that I am very
uncomfortable telling people what they
should be willing to work for and at
what rate so I if they want to join a
union great if they want to kill
themselves for X amount of dollars
because that's what they want to do I
think they should be allowed to and
that's where I sometimes we miss each
other on the internet and online because
ultimately what a forced union is and
and what forced severance are is this
statement from afar that says we know
better than you how to protect
yourselves and so you should not be
permitted to work at this rate of
dollars or without this protection
because we don't think you know what
you're doing and I think that that's
interesting I don't like that from
vilasa philosophically from from a legal
standpoint but I can understand why
people want to get there they want these
people protected and I'm empathetic to
that and I think instead of saying X Y
or Z should happen what I would like to
take from the tell-tale situation is to
say no these people didn't get severance
and that's very risky that's a big
problem living in the san francisco's of
the world if you're just gone tomorrow
and you don't get any severance so let's
make sure people know what it is that
they've contracted for what is the deal
that when you sign an at-will employment
contract which is 95% of all contracts
in America or something along those
lines that this is what it looks like
and if you're not comfortable with that
you asked for more money so you can put
it in a nest egg or you ask for a
severance provision in your contract and
people need to know what it is that
they've agreed to so that they can
better protect themselves and if they
don't realize what they are risking what
they are exposed to you never have that
conversation and you never have that
negotiation
so from my perspective I look at it and
say okay this is bad but rather than
after the fact
let's have everybody wake up and if this
is important to these people that this
is important to these groups to say yeah
all right
let's ask for severance let's put that
in the contracts right now and okay
maybe the company if it runs out of
money goes under three months early but
they get us that severance so that's all
that's all with the understanding that
not only were they mismanaged they
really handled the firing in the wrong
way too I'm not sure what legal counsel
they were in if hold that thought on the
firing go to hit that I don't have you
right now gay can a parent company
insulate yourself from legal action by
having the employees independent
contractors so California has some very
specific definitions for an employee
that's based primarily on hours instead
of their their standing but in general
you don't need that particular
installation for the issue we're talking
about right now because contractors and
employees are both generally at will so
when you talk about the contractor
employee distinction it's usually more
useful in avoiding unions avoiding
collective bargaining and avoiding in
general international regulations and
regulations related specifically to
employees under whatever state you're
operating under but for this particular
purpose which is should severance be
owed should Warren Act notice be given
employers employees and contractors are
not that distinct okay because I run two
companies and under both companies my
employees are independent contractors so
we give them we facilitate the insurance
and stuff like that we like stare them
in the direction of who that they should
have insurance with but we don't provide
insurance for them yeah yeah and there's
reasons to do that and recommendations
for small companies and and and
companies that are doing specific things
there absolutely that independent
contractors make more sense it does
expose people to certain risks that they
wouldn't have necessarily
underemployment but it can also get them
more dollars in their pockets because
you don't have that some kind of
compliance issue
why do you think
why do you think there's there's just
sort of divide between like highly
skilled workers and not be more more so
at will employees rather than like let
you know less you're skilled in sort of
like job types there are the ones that
are being unionized is there something
is it the amount of um a competition
there is at these higher levels that
sort of makes these jobs be more at will
and not be able to unionize these sort
of positions like when you talk about
like game developers being very
technical jobs well we're talking yeah I
mean we're talking about essentially my
thoughts on philosophy and why these
things happen so obviously it's all
speculative but I would say in general
unionization because of what it does
which is it combines a big group of
people into one collective bargaining
unit it tends to work best for jobs and
job types that are relatively
interchangeable that the people within
the collective bargaining unit have very
similar interests and are incentivized
in the same way and when we talk about
high-end artists when we talk about
high-end professionals it tends to make
less sense because we have various we
have very different skill sets and we're
impacting the bottom line or the
strategic structure of the company in
very different ways
so maybe Bob and Susie shouldn't be
treated in a similar collective
bargaining unit because they do such
different things and need to be
motivated and incentivized and
compensated in a different way from what
they're achieving which is a long way of
saying the history of America on unions
has been that line workers are unionized
and management is not for the most part
and that and that stems from that kind
of interchange ability is too strong
but you it you can see where the biases
are there more interchangeable than
management is thought to be Brenda
Noatak you have any uh any questions you
want to Jeff I'm gonna finish up there
like you a yeah I had a quick question
about the four night in a pub G scenario
I know there's a lot of you know
speculation when it comes to working
I'm kind of curious when it comes to
that in general on your you know
professional opinion when it came to
that particular case did you like
obviously you wouldn't know you know
what's going on behind those closed
doors but I'm just kind of curious I'm
like what happened like the reason that
pub G dropped it because I feel like
they wouldn't start it unless they
thought they had something well I mean I
did I think there was to help us out ho
GaN this I will say the pub G fortnight
claim and I think that's Blue Hole vs.
epic was an interesting one primarily
because pub G was made with the Unreal
Engine so unlike other circumstances
where as you probably know from your
copious listening to help us out hog and
reading of legal materials you can't
protect an idea so you can't protect by
registering the notion of a battle
royale game what you can protect is your
personal expression of that and so pub G
can't say you can't have circles you
can't come down from flying things you
can't do these things that fortnight
does but what they could potentially say
is hey epic you helped us work your
Unreal Engine to do these 17 things that
it couldn't otherwise do in order to
make pub G work and as part of our
license there were probably some kind of
confidentiality and intellectual
property assignment provisions in that
contract and we think you breached them
and I think that's what gets them in the
door that's what gets them started out
in having the conversation I don't think
they ever had the intestinal fortitude
to bring it to completion I think I
think something like 99% of disputes
don't wind up going through to to trial
and resolute isn't pretty there's like a
bluff a lot of the times people are
trying to blow you know what did you
think the intent is if they know they're
not willing to go to your way what's the
advantage of that it's to present that
way I think Bluffs a good word is to say
that I've got pocket aces and I'm
willing to take it down and an epic says
no you don't let's let's do this that
car
like you know come in they come in with
that pocket aces like but if you get if
you settle out of court then you know we
won't have to go that direction yes
right we don't try to pull that yeah
well for a litigation for the most part
especially if it's not a real
significant one in terms of damaged
dollars you know who makes the money in
that it's the lawyers right now both
sides paying the lawyers what I think
what I said and that helped us at Hoag
was mmm one thing I could see was pub G
essentially trying to use it as leverage
to lower the royalty on the Unreal
Engine no ending makes money on every
sale of object correct my question is
one question okay in that whole scenario
can blue hole be purchased by another
company while in litigation against epic
yeah
would they or would they have to end
that litigation before they can be
purchased by another company no
Microsoft did they ended the lawsuits of
Microsoft goodbye though know where he's
going with this no they wouldn't have to
from a legal perspective so one of the
things that happens when you enter into
a purchase agreement is there's a big
section that we call representations and
warranties and that's just promises
about the company and one of those
promises would be we don't have any
litigation or if we do here's what it is
we've disclosed it and then there's a
document called a disclosure schedule
that puts down all the exceptions to the
representations and warranties and in
that disclosure schedule would be yes
we're currently being sued by epic
I think they cross suit on that and
you're currently suing I believe some
other Asian developers for for copying
pub G yeah what was it all go on the
disclosure schedule and then Microsoft
or whomever would look at that and take
that under advisement when setting the
identification provisions when setting
the purchase price when setting the
terms of the agreement to say okay no
companies perfect here are the warts and
those warts are going to reduce your
purchase price by two million dollars so
that we can hold it
in case something bad happens or we
think that there's a possibility that
you're gonna gain assets this way so
we're gonna give you a bump up on the
purchase but whatever it looks like
here's how your company is and will
adjust in the money no go
fair enough fair enough Wow any other
questions I was going to close up I
wanted like capitalize a little bit on
what King David said now since they you
know you said chances are they wouldn't
have any kind of legal obligations to be
in any kind of you know lawsuit is there
is from your personal perspective have
you seen companies that don't want to
approach someone while they're currently
in a lawsuit and they want to make sure
that's cooled down before they even do
it I would say in general acquirers
would prefer more certainty rather than
less and a lawsuit is always going to be
a variable so in general they might say
hey wait till that gets sorted out like
apologies and then we can say what
you're really worth so they might say
hey sort it out
settle it whatever and we can reevaluate
mm-hmm possibility
first well salute the law hopefully
answering the questions in the realm the
chat was Lee everyone's loving it man
Laurel dropping the gems today so if
anybody's have any question to get to
the fun so Lord hawk I know you are a
man of legal and gaming respect top 10
list 18 we need to bring you to the
front of the congregation so number one
you had star control origins which I
have not I'm a star control fan so I
have to play before I reserve judgment
the fact that you have with number one
speaks volumes way way better than I
thought it would be exactly so I'm
impressed it I have to touch that number
two you have spider-man which is - Lord
Kings happiness I know he loves that
breed you have Prince of attorney for
dead cells - point Hospital
2.0 hospital you guys get a chance to
play that I have not that's why I cannot
go in on a hospital from bullfrog back
in the day I have not have never playing
a hospital game I know it's sad because
I believe there's a two point is that
the Sega made one is that Sega me oh yes
Sega's yes yes belper and I had my eye
on it and it looked interesting so I
have to give it a shot so I cannot go in
and anything I have not played oh god of
war fantastic maybe we get to number
seven what did I put in I don't I will
give you a full explanation I have two
daughters that want to be scientists
that's that's really the extent of my
explanation I I'm a guy that loved Epcot
Center oh my god that loves edutainment
okay and the process of putting these
things together getting them put
together and then I don't know if you
guys have partaken in lab Oh yourselves
but part of what they do with those is
how does this whole thing work what's
the science behind it how do these
levers work simple machines how do the
infrared sensors work and I think that
is just absolutely fantastic
it works like in the market we're
practicing witchcraft or something over
there to make that as a lord that has
two children two daughters I see where
you're coming from I see with that
creativity is enabled with something
like that and to be able to enjoy that
with you with your kids I can kind of
let you off them I always towards
innovation and I think LeBeau is really
cool and something I haven't seen before
no down run out his list for the Lords
of didn't know he had a compact Ravel er
Dragon Quest 11 in Detroit becomes human
so solid list but I had that
that we still on exclusives on that list
oh very good
and being that spider-man was ranked
higher than God of War you know we
mentioned people yawning me from my
polygon takes on Twitter I tell you war
was only a respect cuz I know he beated
but I am yeah I mean if I was being
snarky I'd say I'm really very much
looking forward to God of War two when
the story actually starts you know there
wasn't a huge spike in the door we want
your knees on the floor I still want to
know how you know the game has a good
just for context Lord Howe oh there's a
bet between Lord kill you Lord Acton
reference to you god of war versus
spider-man and obviously in terms of the
first month sale we know that I got a
war when they launched it did three
million spider-man has done 3.3 so King
is currently in the lead and then once
the month numbers we wait for our good
friend miss can tell it to come on show
and drop that knowledge hopefully and
we'll get the mumps month numbers
because that's the bet they wanted to
those two are going at it
in reference to who's actually gonna
outsell for a full month so it's been
intense as we getting closer to NPD
either way those are some pretty big
sales numbers for both partying in 2018
all right you know man
and last question before we get into
topics um Lord hold top is everyone top
five video games or franchises of all
time and if star controls not on Lisp
you have to talk all right yeah number
one is star control - okay number two is
final fantasy 606 yeah
number three is gonna be Chrono Trigger
number four is probably Witcher 3 Oh
Louis October's loving UHS and then five
always seems to jump around for me was
but it you know it's probably something
off the wall like privateer 2 or
something like that something old-school
in full motion video no it's it's
probably one of those some some space
combat game of some kind some privateer
- Wing Commander for something like that
because I was good at when you talked
about full motion video doing your 3do
Segway was talking about stuff and
that's what I remember right we know for
win command and when you're doing the
dogfights and you have the full motion
video of the guys aliens talking to you
I can still make my brother laugh by
saying you got this thing going
last week's poll results are in and the
people have spoken to the question with
the recent success of Nintendo mini
systems and Xbox backward compatibility
title sales is Sony hypocritical for
announcing both the PlayStation Classic
and PlayStation now download features
after previous previous statements of
gamer non-interest the winner at 54% was
the yes Sony was
until they of the Nintendo mini systems
group covered it at second place was the
no more business move Sony is adapting
to the needs of the market group and
coming in that last place that only six
percent was the I don't care who's
playing Alex anyway it grew thanks to
the Lord's who participated in the poll
yeah they adapted the adapter to the
needs of the market because they saw the
thing is like the second one is worded
in such a way that is like yeah they
adapted because they saw what was
winning and they went that my you know
my issue with is that they copied it
verbatim they did all these companies
copy off one another than once a from
that you know they evolved something
they take an idea that well whatever
this is they said we're doing the exact
same thing you're doing here here take
this and it's like you know come on guys
give me something different man Lord oh
god did you feel about the announcements
of the PlayStation Classic as well as
the ability to download games or to your
hard drive from PlayStation now uh the
PlayStation now download doesn't really
affect me the PlayStation Classic I went
and pre-ordered when it was announced
because I didn't want to get left behind
in case that that proved a problem I you
know it's one of those things where I do
think Microsoft and Xbox has the better
of it in terms of backward compatibility
right now I I really love being able to
pop a disc in there or otherwise spend a
fairly nominal amount to download
whatever it is I'm missing and played on
my xbox 1x so while I really like the
novelty of my mini systems and I'm going
to build a tiny little dollhouse to be
exactly
I do the PlayStation 4 had a more robust
infrastructure for the PlayStation
history yeah I agree I definitely agree
all right so let's have a new poll
cooking up a game that a show please
stay tuned for let's get into these
topics all right so I am up and we got a
brief do this cuz you kind of whole kind
actually went in a little bit or Q&A so
uh telltale they've they've been warned
so to speak it may find himself in legal
trouble regarding a layoff so first of
all I'll definitely want to salute Lord
uh Mike fodder for a tremendous article
a king daily that pays as well as Lord
Hawk himself what is a tremendous
insight and contribution with this so
what's in question here pretty much is
this Warren Act and it's pretty much
requires car applause to be notified in
advance in case these layoffs and pretty
much it's the acronym is the worker
adjustment and Retraining Notification
Act so yeah pretty much
thank you from a lawyer I think so
pretty much is it something to protect
the employees and families of those you
know who are laid off and most employers
with a hundred or more so to provide our
County they if advance notice whenever
these mass layoffs mass closing and in
this case it may not appear to have
happened so I'm a salute again to Mike
with tremendous article you know please
check out if you haven't seen it and um
pretty much they've been named at this
in this tells me naming this as a
defendant in this are warned act class
action lawsuit and I believe that the
gentleman is a vernier ah Bert's so he's
going to be taking them to court and
demand the suit demands are unpaid
payment of unpaid wages and benefits and
like I said the issue comes down to is
you know telltale going to be
responsible for this so based on what
you know in your input on this Lord
Hogan you've got to start with you you
know what do you feel about the basis of
this Warren Act and if they're in
violation with this class action lawsuit
yeah so obviously with the same
disclaimer as always which is not legal
advice from an educational only
the the crux of it is the Warren Act was
put in place and so that companies
couldn't just evaporate large numbers of
jobs without giving people a warning and
letting them look for a new landing
place and that that warning period is 60
days what happened here appears to be
that the company was seeking funding had
funding lined up had a term sheet
entered into in all likelihood and then
when the definitive documents were about
to be signed
probably one we know Lionsgate at least
but maybe more than one financing source
backed out and then that cascaded the
financing once your leave backs out
everybody looks at it and says well I
don't want to do it if it's not X amount
of dollars and so it all falls apart and
then the next day they say oh we can hit
this payroll and no more guys and that's
a Warren Act problem because
California's Warren Act is different
than the federal Warren Act so the
federal Warren Act says if you've got a
scenario where your capital raising and
it falls through
if you close a whole plant the
vernacular obviously leaning more
towards manufacturing but it still
generally applies under the way the
statute is written if you close a whole
plant then you're don't it's not your
fault you tried we don't want to
penalize people that were trying to make
the company work and it didn't and it
didn't work out if you don't close the
whole plant then you don't get to use
that exception instead you wind up in an
exception that says if there were
unreasonable business or circumstances
and we're not gonna then we're not going
to ding you either so the federal Warren
Act gives you this kind of gray area to
say oh we were gonna get money we
thought we were gonna get money we have
every reason to believe we're gonna get
money we have people coming in next week
we just hired people this week and it
didn't happen and so we're very sorry
but we have to go away right now or Nia
like many states copies the federal law
and changes it in little ways okay what
they don't you apply to telltale is they
took the federal law and there's an
exception for capital funding capital
raises that fall through there's an
exception for
contracts that are of a specific term
things like that what they didn't bring
over to their version of the statute was
this exception for unenforceable
businesses so because the capital
funding provision only applies to a full
closing we start to talk about whether
telltale is fully closed and they're not
they're not because they still retain
stuff yeah you're right 25 people to
help you finish off the Netflix contract
right and they don't appear to have
fully closed oh because California
doesn't have that business circumstances
test I think in all likelihood telltale
can defeat a federal Warren Act
violation claim we can't defeat a
Californian one God should just stop you
for one quick second breaking it down
and I believe the third exception was
like on the federal level was actually
like a natural disaster or something to
that effect right terrorist attack yeah
okay so that didn't happen obviously so
the thing is now what was filed at this
point by Vernie Robertson these guys
until was this on the federal level or
on the Californian version of the WARN
Act do we know that right now my
understanding is he filed in federal
court for a violation of both so and I
tweeted this out because I was in this
article that Mike put together there's
that title oh yeah yeah you guys killed
that you and I yes but I so I did
mention that the federal just what I
said just now which is that they
probably can beat a federal claim but
they filed for federal anyway and what I
tweeted out was from a legal strategy
point of view yeah you file both because
they still have to prove that it was an
unforeseeable business circumstances and
you might win that you never know so you
file both I think they probably get the
federal one defeated but I don't know
what argument they could have against
the California one which is what I wrote
in that article which is from where I'm
at which is a Michigan lawyer some
thousand miles away but looking at the
statutes and looking at everything else
I don't see how they can beat the
California claim but you start talking
about you know what does that mean yeah
they wind up owing these
60 days of wages they didn't get 60 days
of work so it's just a penalty amount
and where does that fall under the
amounts that the tell-tale otherwise
owes to people like their landlord or
the people that bought the Walking Dead
final season that bought that season
remove predators of the company they
have given money to the company and
haven't received the assets they
purchased yes it's I just want to cut
you in for two quick thing I know I know
I got like bloody talked about talk
myself
um the thing it reminds me of is I was a
fan of Marvel heroes and when it finally
came to console and I believe the
company was gazillion and it's this is
eerily similar to that where they
brought it to console and then the
company just goes through goes under and
then at that point you know everything
that was kind of old was I mean I
remember purchasing packs a future
content or whatever it may be so like
you're saying you kind of mentioned like
a creditors there's like so at that
point for those people who bought the
latest season of Walking Dead right you
know is it gonna be as most likely a
similar situation where they have to
credit these people because I believe
you know I was credited as in reference
to Marvel heroes when that situation
happened so when I say creditor I mean
that like they're like a bank right
they've essentially lent money to tell
tale and tell tale is supposed to do
something to get that to earn that money
Mike actually has an excellent article
if you go into his stuff on on gamedaily
where he discusses the notion of
unearned revenue which is an accounting
term but it basically means what I'm
saying here which is that you've gotten
paid and you haven't delivered your side
of the bargain
so in the case of Marvel heroes and
isn't it interesting that we're talking
about these two circumstances that both
relate to third-party licenses and what
those business models look like in that
case it's a matter of who is partnered
with them what kind of damage control
they need to do I don't know what kind
of credit you got whether that you got
anything from Sony Direct whether you
got anything from Vermillion but it's a
matter of what assets exist I mean when
we're talking about if they lose this
warrant at case if they've otherwise
has not got a Walking Dead Season four
whatever the final season number is done
who gets paid yeah and that's what I
talked about on my Twitter which is if
I've got a sack of fifty dollars and I
owe a hundred dollars and you want to
throw the employees in there with a
Warren Act claim that's fine but if I
owe a hundred dollars it's not a matter
of evil or what's trying to be despotic
it's a matter of this is the money we
have how does it get divvied up Presi
people are gonna experience pain who
deserves the pain who gets the pain
depends on what the contracts say
depends on how a bankruptcy estate would
treat the assets that's why the Warren
Act claim is then silly is that it can
get you a space in line in that process
right but it doesn't mean they're gonna
get 60 days of money my guess is that
doesn't exist mmm so in those cases when
it doesn't exist that what pop it's like
these guys just don't get anything like
like they just don't have it when a camp
when a company goes under it has these
hard assets a software company is going
to have furniture and computers and it's
gonna have some cash amount it's gonna
owe money to probably its licensed
partners depending on what it owes under
its royalty agreements it's gonna oh my
knee to the people that bought the
Walking Dead Season four it's gonna owe
money to its landlord and for any
contracts that it breaches if it go if
it does go under and it's potentially
gonna owe money to its employees under a
Warren Act claim and then we decide who
gets a quarter and who gets a dime and
who gets a nickel Wow and there it is
what a chiming oh Lord addict theity in
feelings on this the whole telltale
thing upsetting but I understand how you
know business works and I understand
that they were put in a box and maybe
they didn't disclose it to the you know
employees because they didn't want to
affect the the work rate and they were
hoping that this bag will come in and
the bag didn't show up and when the bag
doesn't show up everything goes laughs
and have to be truthful and honest with
these guys but as far as keeping a
business
is open with 25 employees that was
stupid
I mean again we're guessing but my guess
based on what we know the 25 people are
putting minecraft through for Netflix if
you remember they had a Netflix contract
for stranger things and my guess is I
came to an arrangement about what would
be considered a breach and what money
they would owe to Netflix and part of
that solution was you'll finish
minecraft for us and my guess is when
you're in these crisis scenarios you
don't always call your labor lawyer and
you don't always figure out what the
potential problem with that approach is
and the so I think they they foot
faulted they slipped accidentally into a
Warren Act violation I think it exists
but they were trying to appease Netflix
and not get sued for whatever stranger
things money had already been given to
them etc etc right gotcha gotcha lords
sovereign and you know input on the Koko
situation just quickly on that um how
did cuz I know that there was some
belief online or confusion as to how
that works how they get those licenses
are they paying these license holders to
to use the license in their games or is
it is it sort of somewhere in the middle
or is it vice versa they're paying them
yeah they're the the question is how
much money was paid up front how much do
they owe for existing royalties etc etc
and and where there could be a a back
and forth when I talk about stranger
things money is sometimes there's an
advance on what is going to be royalty
sometimes there's here's some here's
this chunk of money for development you
can pay us back in sales etc etc I don't
know what that looks like that's
complete speculation and what we do know
is whatever telltale was entering into
it wasn't working in terms of keeping
them in the black so those contracts
could be god-awful I don't know yeah
yeah just finished up - it's just the
failed whole situation is sad I mean
when the way they started it just how
you know they just seemed like this
vibrant new company that they had this
new genre of narrative storytelling that
really wasn't done before I never forget
the walking dead you know season one and
the emotional ending and just to see you
know we were like where's it gonna go
next and
you know I definitely seemed like that
maybe they just took one too much you
know and you know they just had so many
private projects guardians of the galaxy
I remember Game of Thrones it was this
one that was all strangers to companies
closing data East all the companies of
that nature you know we've we've been
through I mean our history and video
games have shown us that if you don't
stay this Capcom was looking like they
were I was worried about that but we've
seen companies fall that we're at the
height and have very good game so I mean
these games are time capsules yeah I
understand we are probably more upset
about the employees more than we are
about the actual company because we see
companies absolutely I just like I said
I guess for my it was a surprise to me
I'll be honest I didn't think that
everything was rosy on on the telltale
side but it was a surprise you know
because again like they were just it
felt like they were just pumping out
content constantly and just to see like
wow going under effective boom and I
must wait I mean how many shouldn't be
Thanos snapped out of existence and that
that but that really goes to you should
have had Inklings they should have been
paring back they should have been doing
other things and they weren't yeah I
guess I'm saying for the next out of it
I think the biggest thing that happened
with them you know is I think it was
fatigue I think a couple like small
little things they could've did I think
if the company would have dedicated
every year to a certain game and not I
mean why is it now that six years later
we're getting the final season of The
Walking Dead good point the time that
how it was they didn't care yeah the
argument is a lot of people felt that
one they didn't upgrade your engine fast
enough they did they would like just
recently it was that I found pretty fans
I think people were tired
of that kind of you know engine that
kind of gameplay but I think for the
most part that they didn't paste their
games correctly to actually capitalize
with that whole with the whole aspect of
it again I'm gonna double down on it the
Internet is a terrible troll when you
can look at these story
yes story games and you can just sit
there eat a bowl of cereal and watch the
whole damn story on YouTube by somebody
playing it easy you don't have to
actually go out and purchase he's been
doing that you know there's a lot of
people that do that especially if you
watch something like that onto a twitch
you're probably not gonna buy the game
but let's say you know someone like me
I'm the first I enjoyed the first two
but by you know we're like two years
from the last one right so it's gotten
to the point where I'm like you know
what I just I just watch it on Twitch I
don't I don't care like so attic your
point is more so that you know while the
fire is hot with the more famous ones
like the walk the only one I've seen
them even remote didn't they have to
spider-man Co not spider-man um yes see
that one looked a little bit more bed or
pacing because by the time the second
one came out people were still
remembering the first I suit you same as
you saying you talked about that gap
that weight just like you do have and
then I think that the die between the
episodes is a little bit too far
sometimes and and you just when it comes
to episodic games like that I think you
need their hat you have two choices you
need to go the direction that you know
that untell Don went where you just
released a whole season and I think
you'd have a little bit more better
choice with that if you don't if you're
not able to pop out the content in a
reasonable amount of time because it's
like TV shows what's about two months
goes by I'm already waiting for the
season I'm not gonna watch every episode
individually listen I hear there's a lot
of factors here
yeah I think I think what it comes down
to it they didn't game of Phi that
engine enough it came to a point with it
I think those engines lend to a specific
group right and I don't yeah
but the attic point right if you look at
until dawn right until dawn is one game
right it's not a it's not season let's
say this right let's say okay everybody
keeps bringing up this hunt until dawn
against these telltale Detroit did the
same thing okay this is what I'm gonna
try to explain to you those telltale
games cater to a very specific crowd
that can be either super casual
neighbors more or hardcore gamers right
that engine is palatable for those three
bright areas
now you have the until dawn and the
Detroit they cater to to the hardcore
and the above casual type of crowd you
understand so super casual crowd is
gonna do it they don't wanna look at uh
the whole engine and stuff like that
it's just I felt that like you said
maybe it's true what you said that they
didn't come up with the next season's
fast enough but maybe they took on too
much - too many licensees all over the
place and was trying to pump out all
these different games like you had
guardians head then you had Batman and
then okay on the back burner we do walk
in there later but people that want to
walk in there now then walked away from
that and then by the time Walking Dead
did come out they were like oh we're
past that we're watching on twitch when
it comes to that the reason that they
chose that direction and I think that's
another key reason why they went over
under is because you know you know Lord
Richard I'm pretty sure when they had
that opportunity they didn't know if
that would be here two years from now a
year from now so when they was able to
get those licensing agreements I think
that you know they grabbed them without
really thinking the consequences to take
me much on yeah good because I do agree
with the with the issues with with
twitch I think that telltale was
uniquely situated to get burned by
people watching their product and in an
industry that's still dealing with
folks that want to stream from twitch
and and justifiably so they weren't able
to do what probably they they should
have done which is essentially ban their
games from being streamed yeah public
relations nightmare for them based on
based on where the industry sits right
this second but in terms of the product
that they actually have there is value
lost when yes what is primarily the
source of interest from playing a
telltale game for me was the notion of
getting into the character's head and
deciding on how you're gonna treat this
answer this response totally because it
puts you into a television show or a
book in a way that you wouldn't
otherwise be when you're playing
something like Game of Thrones which is
one of their lesser works but you have
to say wow what are the ways that I
could answer this where I don't get
burned by Queen Cersei that's even if
you know that you're always gonna get
burned but it's still interesting to be
like one of my thoughts and you get the
four and you have the timer and that's
interesting but you lose 90% of it from
just watching it and not yeah absolutely
and the last point I'll make it look
definitely more and what just things
that actually have a feature in some of
the games were they integrated it into
streaming yes so you know I think they
were trying to encourage that they're
like I think but when it comes to this
it may be they were under charging for
the product they were giving because
that's what a lot of people don't
realize this this game was only $25 25
right under charging for maybe you know
if they would have invested more into an
engine and had a better product they
could have charged 40 to 60 with the
whole season I mean it's just a lot of
different things but that was an impulse
buy from me because when I see a
telltale game I said oh I would say the
last year from me cuz I felt the same
way but the last year the last couple of
seasons of content even the 25 for me
was like I wait for a sale no way and
that's because that that you know that
sensation of wanting to see what happens
next left because they took
putting our season pass is on sale
before the season for the season I think
that let's move on I mean the last thing
I'm definitely it's just that I about
when was gonna say is that like I felt
like what happened is also another
factor was that you know unfortunately
that structure even though you may quote
unquote significant choices during the
middle of the game and like Laurel was
saying about you know you got to see
what you're gonna say to Cersei whatever
whatever ultimately the game kind of got
back on Rails towards the end and it
didn't really like branch off into
completely different paths I felt you
know I'm saying at the end that way your
choice is kind of really like wow this
game completely changed
yeah you're an adventure why exactly and
I felt a competition then caught up you
had the life of strangers you had the
Detroits right you know where they took
up on that formula the engine was better
and they had more significance I can
remember specific things in life is
strange and you know Detroit where the
game is completely different based on
said past and said choices and I just
think I think they kind of like evolved
the fauna but that's just my opinion
whatever give you that there's a lot of
people that took that concept and made
it better and they did all their own
involve any kind of state we think oh we
got to move on monumental news on the
Sony for Lord AG do you want to talk
about cross for you I'm gonna grab it
I'm sorry I didn't hear the monumental
selling front Louis leaf no I was
talking when it comes to the whole cross
play thing what I really just wanted to
bring up is you know obviously we know
now that Sony did cave to the cross play
and I love because I made a video on
YouTube and what I did when I use the
word cave you wouldn't believe how many
people call me so didn't cave to
anything they did it the table and just
get your guys's overall opinion and
whether an IV like you about
like whether or not you know this came
from a position of weakness or it was
I've actually been seen on Twitter that
people really believe that Sony has
implied this and it's been a long time
in the going but now they're there
they're actually launching Lord Hawk
what do you feel about the cross play
being allowed in fortnight I think it's
fantastic I you know I had said that I
thought that they would give us cross
progression at some point because I
think it's easy enough to let the third
parties have their accounts mm-hmm I
didn't think that they would open the
doors to cross play I suspect that it
was just easier to open the whole thing
and not but I think this is I think I
tweeted it out the day it happened I
think it's a huge huge day for gaming
and I think that it is fantastic for all
gamers no matter their console war
persuasion that could do that but
fortnight good fortnight Wi-Fi by
getting their employees 1.2 billion
dollars I believe that they said they
are that their game generated to the
staff that that speaks volumes like this
game is it's taken on a world of its own
like I I don't play the game but I know
tons of people who do and the seed that
it took a game of this magnitude to
force the need to hit the ground for
Sony because we thought that that wasn't
gonna happen I actually thought it was
never gonna happen then what I got three
dozen tweet that went out right yeah I
wrote at e3 when when people were
launching their switches their switch
fortnight's
and getting that message that said no
you want to use disowning one time in
your life no you can't okay that was
going to play wrong for everybody and to
be cool I think that epic was doing that
deliberately if you read that note it's
like you know go talk to Sony they're
being asses and I think it was workable
I tweeted out at the time I said I
think that fortnight is going to break
them I did that's gonna be cross
progression I didn't think it was gonna
be cross play so I think that's gonna
open the floodgates and I think it's
gonna be everything I think you know the
next the next call should be to
Activision and bungee and say let's go
[Applause]
you know I don't think it's gonna happen
probably the next year I think sooner or
later especially when it how it worked
out for tonight because they open the
floodgate now there's no shutting it
waiting it with one the it's not gonna
happen for a little bit but I do think
sooner or later you know after enough
harassment to the other communities the
Destiny community the call of duty
community um Dora no I I see them
opening it to them to because they're
all pushing for it they are me but I
don't you tonight is being played on
Jimmy Kimmel show I think it was
entirely fortnight I think but does that
had something to do with the to because
every time this was even remotely dying
but des they would come out be like yo
they still ain't letting us do it like
have a game big enough to force the hand
it's like if they use their actual games
as leverage Sony would at the cave
fallout 76 being an xbox exclusive would
devastate the best in this whole
situation I wanted to comment on it
because at the end of the day obviously
you know they were very vocal
you know during before sassonique across
by announcement you know they were very
vocal that they wanted it especially for
their Elder Scrolls Legend and I believe
it was a Pete Hines from Bethesda he
basically came out and said it was
pertinent to legend that you know this
was so critical for the game to have
cross play so the question I want to
bring the little hog with this is that
you know now that it is allowed right
and as far as in the fort night
situation right you know I've seen a lot
of Twitter banter
back and forth saying well now you know
Sony kind of exposed but there's this
hand because now they've allowed it so
why won't you now allow it in or work
towards getting Fallout 76 done because
this this statement right after fallout
after the announcement with Sony in
fortnight are they but that's actually
said no we're not doing fallout 7076
anymore that that's already locked into
not cross play so Laura what do you feel
about this whole Bethesda thing
involvement you know is somebody called
a bluff like what do you feel about the
situation no I think the infrastructure
is such that you probably can't turn on
a dime I think from Sony's perspective
it's great that they did this for
fortnight I think it's baby steps for
them I think they still need to be shown
that it's not going to negatively impact
their bottom line which I firmly believe
it won't I think it will be actually a
positive for them but they have to they
have to see that and then I think what
you're talking about really is a future
of cross play rather than a present
fortnight's enough to break this because
epoch was ready
I mean fortnight I don't know if you
remember you saw a couple instances
where they had accidentally turned on
cross play it was clearly just a dam
that Sony had built so it's a matter of
epic saying great you're in Sony and we
hit the button versus Sony being very
adamant to Bethesda and saying you can't
cross play we're worried about safety or
whatever other garbage they said leading
to leading to a fallout 76 that is built
to be separate if there is a secret
button we haven't seen any indication of
it so I suspect you're talking about
next year and the years beyond being in
a situation where gaming community can
come together and play together yeah I
mean ultimately I think it's the open
more importantly like you said I think
from greatest cross play is I think the
futures cross progression and I think
that was key as far as the whole epic
accounts being held hostage you know I'm
saying that wasn't right if you you know
if you log into a Sony account machine
and then you know then water switch like
you said and you got that infamous mess
I mean we were out there on the floor
Lord King you know saying we remember
like the fortnight and was roller skates
I'm an even-tempered guy you can't you
can't do that Sony that's not right
yeah and it was the negative I've never
seen such a negative backlash and I
spoke about this well to the shop pal
cause I was with those guys last night
you know saying ptk blam and it grew and
on we thought it was funny because I
almost felt at that moment Microsoft and
Nintendo sensed weakness and then you
started to see more of the marketing of
surviving like sir is it was what was
the survive together and then I was like
okay I guess so it had to be something
of a juggernaut an unstoppable force to
do this and if that if that game doesn't
exist in a form that it's in now
I agree King that it had to be that's
the monumental nature of fortnight
because it had to be a game of that
school that size to get them to even
consider it and have new Kings on it
like I don't know if another game could
have done it I'm saying since they open
at the fortnight they gave they have
given other publishers rise probably ask
for but then they're gonna say just like
this well when you generate 40 billion
in sales now let us do that then leave
us alone we gotta say no to you get out
the door and close it so no I don't
think it's a one-time deal I think again
if there's something free-to-play that
comes down the pipeline that has this
similar type of Appeal the question is
gonna come up again right I didn't think
it was a you know fortnight definitely
was the key reason and I don't even
think it was you know it was the
pressure they're getting from the
commune
there's uh you know how many times I saw
people say well you know what I'm just
gonna go ahead and play it on PC because
I want to play it on the switch or vice
versa or something else like that like
all it takes and that's been the reason
that happened is because that cross play
was already implied so put that pressure
on Sony
so if do you think that if they get the
same amount of pressure from the
community across the board from a game
that's considered a less popular game
but the same amount of pressure you'd
think at some point they cave
you can't generate the same amount of
pressure without the same amount of
revenue you know this is money driven
all right you gotta understand that part
right there the issue that made this
happen is that they locked the
progression behind Sony if the account
was huge motivated at all because people
were upset that they couldn't take it
somewhere else okay that's the point
that I'm saying when you have millions
of people who say okay I want to play it
on this I'm gonna play it on that and
then I'm gonna go home and I'm gonna
play it on my playstation and then you
log into your other thing that you
wanted to play it on it says now you
can't do that because these guys to know
then that's when the upset over why
don't going that sooner or later a lot
more of these games are just start to be
more cross progression across
cross-platform once you see imagine if
something like destiny was you know I
would like to imagine that yes oh but if
that happened can Sony say no at that
point yeah because that's the question
King because the precedent because not
set like it the flood gate is open it'll
be harder for them to deflect but I do
see your point King that you still have
to be another game of that stature it's
not going to be Sony caving to the
consumers it's gonna be Sony caving to
Activision because people are blowing
they [ __ ] up
and I know imagine let's say that
destiny is we're just gonna use destiny
cuz we all play that all right cross
play like you know we could play off a
bond Tucson battle.net how long can sony
take that criticism that they're not let
they're not let me let me give it let me
give it the whole because I think hole
also said at the point between sense
that they have to present to Sony hey
look look how beneficial this is Friday
actually right they would have to
wouldn't you think Lord hole like they
would have to do it in some fashion that
way the other companies here's what I'll
say I agree with really both of you on
this I think that fortnight needed to be
as big as it is to make Sony listen but
I do think that every time this happens
and this might be the straw that breaks
the camel's back it becomes more and
more likely that it will be the general
approach to most of the games because
the standard of expectation changes mmm
cross play and cross progression is
expected it is much more clearly blocked
when someone moves to block it I would
say I would say Sony is going to battle
this one or two more times but after
they lose those battles it's just going
to be a standard for every day I think
the pendulum shifts I think more tonight
is a big move and I and I think yes I
would really like to play my warlock on
my PC well you know anything that moves
us towards that will will be very happy
i I approach it from a slightly
different perspective I understand all
your perspectives and they make absolute
sense especially when it comes to
revenue but I think with Sony for me at
some point the market leader has to take
a position of leadership and they and I
mentioned this before I feel once they
got to a position of power they were
playing more to not lose as opposed to
playing to win when you let the number
two and then the number three guys take
the heat on things like this obviously
they're taking they're taking the lead
from a position of losing where they
need to do these sorts of things to
appeal more to people and say hey look
we're doing things we're doing right by
the game when the when the person in
power is not taken
lead on these big things it's the optics
are bad and we've seen how the narrative
continues on a dime 2013 that narrative
changed on a dime for an Xbox mmm and
Sony is not immune to it as powerful as
they are this this generation they're
not immune to that narrative changing
and just so but that's what I mean is
what it means to be for the players
shifts and I think it's shifted pretty
significantly this last week and in a
good way
and I think to the extent that for the
players now requires a certain at least
openness across the way across the
ration that's ultimately gonna break the
dam someday right okay good I think
there's certain games and certain genres
that once that genre still I think once
the first-person shooter genre takes off
in cross plate there's no going back
you saw the Xbox Twitter account like
like I could just picture he did the
same exact thing that came oh yeah
that's why I've been the need for
everybody so I think everybody I think
they sent a high-five emoji I think that
was I think then cross play but sooner
or later we'll see both of them moral to
be that space that space has to be
worked in because like the genesis of
everything is like peer gaming right so
we come from a whole the whole culture
of gaming has always been together this
we turned to this separatist type of
mentality I don't
I guess when the console was really
started happening when they started
making big bucks
they started separating us and now we
got to this point where we're at now and
we all want to come together now so yeah
listen at the end of the day this is
great the game is that soft that was you
talking hope I'm sorry let's hope that
was you I don't want
oh yeah just pretty much I just think at
the end of day this is great for gaming
you know I honestly didn't think it
would happen this Jen I thought it would
definitely happen next gen I didn't in a
position of power there was no need for
them to play ball so to speak and again
it just showed me the testament of
fortnight as much as I have my little
issues with fortnight's ethics with the
verbs you situation you know I have to
give credit where credit is due it's a
phenomenon in you know lawful place they
should bend the knee yeah I mean listen
it happened you know they did they did
acquiesce so let's move on this one
would be super quick as we're over time
and I know Lord and it Christie I've
seen this in the Twitter community and I
want to shout out Lord Kofi he's brought
it up I want to shout so what will
impress Starr shout out to those dudes
I've seen the feedback on Twitter and it
comes down to these dance emotes and we
all know they've been around no destiny
does it we know for tonight is
definitely on the top of this list
horizon for the series yep was horizon
has danced amongst
it for the first time well for society
how transported seven had it um so now
you have an avatar that gets out of the
car you're not getting out of a car no
but you have an actual avatar that you
can customize and do stuff with so yes
they are dancing it's crazy how trends
change it's crazy and then I know NBA 2k
is always done when you're walking
around in my park or whatever once I you
know and you know these guys Millie
rocking and a lot of hip hop culture
dances so you know I wanted to bring
this to Lord Howe and on just from to
get the legal perspective in in the
sense that you know a lot of we've seen
a lot of pushback from these artists and
programming a lot of artists from
hip-hop culture where they're saying hey
you know if you guys are gonna you know
take our dancers we should at least get
credit for it you know we should at
least be if not any monetization maybe a
link to that artists page so that the
user who's playing the video game
understands the origins of where it
comes from you know because as of right
now a lot of these dances are renamed
right I remember like destiny had the
whole Michael Jackson Thriller
the whole video I was like wow like even
about there is some my dance move over
there a pay phone like I said the Milly
rock and all these famous hip hop
dancers oh right from a legal standpoint
you know is there anything that an
artist can do to protect these moves or
is it's just a lost cause you know with
litigation how do you feel about so the
nature of litigation is such that
anybody can sue anybody for anything no
you can you can always make a claim the
question is how quickly will it get
defeated and kicked out of court mmm
dance moves and choreography in general
as an expression yes and be protected
under under copyright but it is one of
them one of the less litigated and more
controversial isn't right but but not as
certain types of protections that you
can get it's not like copy writing a
book or trademarking a brand name so
when you talk about something like say
the Thriller dance you see that dance
pop up in a number of instances and I
don't know if you remember in the
original plants vs. zombies there was a
there was a Michael Jackson zombie any
general ER thing as he moved across the
lining that got that got changed
mmm and if you think about that the
reason it got changed is that that
zombie originally had a sparkly red vest
jacket and one white sparkly glove and
they said well that's that's clearly
Michael Jackson doing thriller as a
zombie and Electronic Arts said yeah all
right well I might have just been pop
cap at the time but yeah you got this
what will get that taken care yeah all
right that's fine and that's how these
legal things often work especially with
big companies is we'll do it and see if
anybody comments so my favorite where my
favorite parts of fortnight which I have
played
because I had to earn the lollipop girl
for my girls is that the initial dance
is Turks dance fraught to poison from
Scrubs
okay so I love that show and I noticed
it immediately and you look at that you
say well that's that's an existing dance
that's turk dancing in scrubs and we
know who can stop it and one probably
nobody probably nobody copyrighted that
choreography you could go talk to Donald
Faison or whoever owned scrubs at this
point but probably it's not that big of
a deal and if it proved to be a big of a
deal you know they'd get contacted from
someone who has a plausible claim to the
ownership and they'd say fine we'll pull
it because that's not what's driving the
sales here into the most part if it
something like fortnight looks at it and
says yeah if your if your dance is
recognizable chances are that's
advertising for you we talked about
what's allowed what's legal what can get
you sued a whole lot of stuff can get
you sued the question is whether or not
you can justify it in a way that makes
sense to the party that might be able to
sue you so when we talk about streaming
on Twitch a lot of that probably isn't
fair use a lot of that that the person
that owns the intellectual property
rights to that video game could probably
order a takedown notice and ask you to
take it down and/or sue you but you know
Nintendo does it all the time but the
rest of the industry has basically
decided it's good free advertising so
it's a matter of what's allowed and who
really wants to settle on what what
should be litigated and in the case of
which everybody's pretty happy with it
being ambiguous because if they decide
someone's gone too far they can send a
cease and desist to him and you can't
really look at a court case that says no
no I'm allowed to I'm allowed to stream
this I'm fine because nobody's willing
to go all the way in terms of in terms
of litigating it and that's useful both
to the twitch streamers as well as to
the holders of the intellectual property
so for dances you get a similar
situation yeah if I can identify the
Beyonce
single ladies dance or I can identify
perfect shrubs then hey maybe that's
something that they have choreography
rights to but do they want to sue me and
do they want to make trouble and chances
are if they had a problem with it if if
fortnight weren't cartoony and friendly
and everybody loved it but it was
violent and had some other appalling
aspects to it you might have scrubs or
NBC or you might have Beyonce or you
might have this Michael Jackson or
whoever come and say hey I don't want to
be on your murder simulator to you but
for tonight's super popular it doesn't
hurt anybody
you're not losing views of single ladies
or for this being in fortnight you're
just having people remember that hey
that was on scrubs maybe I should watch
that on Netflix or Hulu or wherever it
lives I want I want to I want to fly
well I want to follow that's a great
point I want to follow up in a sense
that the argument the I want to say the
quote-unquote ethical argument right is
that what they're saying is especially
the hip-hop community is saying that a
lot of these popularized dance that at
least if they were given their name
mention of all the the actual a because
a lot of times these dances let's be
honest are renamed when you open up for
a night or you open up destiny like I
remember seeing these dances and it was
called something completely different in
context to death the other poles to the
artist you know what about that aspect
from the ethical side that you know if
you're not gonna give us monetization
you're gonna say hey you giving us free
advertising about you even recognizing
your dance move but like you know could
you at least credit the artist or
something to that effect do you think
they have any stance on that or that's
gonna get like shut down it's hard you
know the little guys the choreographers
that aren't represented by a big company
and maybe did something cool they saw it
on a YouTube video yeah and epic or
Activision says yeah let's put that in
they don't have they don't have the
money they don't have the leverage they
don't have the threatening capability to
come after them so you could take
advantage of it and I arguably that is
probably in atha chol for the borrowing
between you know if if Activision saw
something cool on fortnight and put in
destiny or vice versa
there's a there's a come at me bro kind
of ass
yeah they could sue if they want to but
chances are again to the extent they
link to each other
it's a I saw that on destiny oh right
doesn't he exists I need to play gambit
for another seven hours unlikely to
cause damage so it's probably unethical
to potentially the individuals
potentially the small actors it might be
illegal but it's not you know if I were
advising these guys again tweets not
legal advice podcast appearances not
legal advice it's one of those where
yeah you're probably not gonna get
burned by it because somebody can't
probably sue you so yeah let your ethics
be your guide let your moral compass be
your guide but from a legal standpoint
you're not probably talking about
liability exposure hunches keeping it
real Lord hold this got appreciate you
for that I would thank you so much
minutes absolutely happy to beyond
absolutely wrap this thing up man a new
ILP poll this week with the recent
announcement by Sony to allow for at
night cross play between multiple
platforms is it fair to now expect
Bethesda to include fallout 76 cross
play based on their previous stance
involving Elder Scrolls legends the
choices are a yes Sony has now exposed
Bethesda the previous statements and
closed core called their bluff be no
unreasonable expectation for Bethesda
based on a time frame of sony's
announcement or C I don't care whose
Brando's buggy bethesda games anyway
lord outstanding fan of your work man we
couldn't get enough yeah I could talk to
you all day but I know your lions are
playing and we gotta all get back to
football but I really want to salute you
man thank you so much for coming through
and wicked to find people find you and
what else do you have going on yeah
absolutely well thanks for inviting me
on you know they can find me if they
need business legal advice on Hope Lodge
OE GLA wor
or otherwise as I said I'm talking video
games and sports and Cavanagh hearings
on at Hoag law h EG l aw on twitter
whoa saluteth this got please he is a
fantastic follow on twitter please
follow hope please again and for my
lords that need that legal advice please
halogen man this guy really knows his
stuff you know great mind it's great in
a community true game and loves gaming
and an absolute honor to have you and do
we have to bring you back at all do that
it would be much appreciated because
your insight is really valuable a lot of
gamers don't understand how things work
we've learned so much today
thank you again Lord hold the firm
without fear that's what I call love
Abed Luke being in a rumble or to
dealing with our foolishness Lord addict
what is going on wicked if I people find
you what you got going on you can find
me on Twitter at Lord addict ILP I'm
about to make a video actually on
whether or not destiny is too hard so I
definitely look on that for coming on
absolutely Lord sob in the realm as
usual where can I find people find you
besides playing force in 4k ultra
settings all that crazy until Red Dead
comes out playing for them playing Tomb
Raider you can find me on xbox live on
Twitter Lord Saibaba pbx sovereign on
Xbox Live and PSN and definitely big
shout out to Lord Rick Hulk I mean I
love the insights man because again we
as gamers we're kind of we're entitled
right we want one one one one we don't
know when that takes we're taking what
it takes to get there sometimes
so knowing to be brought down to earth
actually educated access right yeah
absolutely Lord
let out here beats what they so debased
first of all first and foremost Lord
hope thank you for showing up and
answering that question I had with the
Disney Foxx acquisition and calm yes
yeah that was really plaguing me for a
couple of days and like you really
played that up from yeah at first you
know I was afraid that Comcast was gonna
do what they was doing you know raising
the price of Fox and all that other
stuff but you know I see they came to a
good resolution to it and I just want to
know where the money was well not like I
was getting any of it okay so you guys
can find me on your destiny in the clan
that we're about to cut down lore
Cognito and myself and tack is gonna sit
together if you have not played destiny
and you're in this clan you have not
played in the last 12 days you are out
unless your Godfather in and those
people that know their Channel five
members so that that that speaks volumes
so if you don't understand what I just
said and you're 12 days out you better
login you better start getting a network
right now because if you got in just to
get the whisper fought alert you're done
son look at the orbit combat talk what
is gonna come up I'm doing my research
too just to flushed out the back end of
it also Kos is coming you don't
understand what that means but you
wouldn't know what it means soon I can
give you a view on some of the stuff
that's piling up right there so that's
gonna be part of the Kos and I'll
explain that later but we have a lot of
things happen and we have big
announcements coming we wanted to have a
big announcement for you guys today
but intellectual properties and people
came up and blocked us so they send a
lawyers out the shutters and they holds
in us
so yeah but they're to get fixed in we
have a big announcement coming for you
guys and you will love it yes sir we
wanted to break it but we have to work
out the kinks we'll get that straight
now and again double down on what Lord
King was saying in reference to Lord
Hawk with the Marvel stuff I want to
implore you Lords I mean he's a big fan
he has great content he actually has a
YouTube channel that I'm gonna plug from
folklore please check out his YouTube
channel and he has a fantastic video on
the MCU the whole evolution of that
generation to infinity war fair and
North Hawk was also my source during
those painful times of the Disney
Comcast Fox you know they're battling
that's right is it gonna get finalising
you like it's happening I'm nervous it's
always a snag comcast it's gotta happen
and he gave me that insurance and it
sure enough it did happen so again big
MCG fan is well here so please check
them out at a channel or yeah man that's
what I got
so um as far as us you already know we
can find us from the inner circle
Network obviously the affiliates shout
out to all the people the links will be
in description shout out to boycott so
we'll get the timestamps up you'll know
about that and of course the stream team
Lords now though all those guys el
boogie working them re-- Barrios who
star all the crew we're gonna work to
get this thing a little bit refined a
little bit and get these guys on so um
yeah that's what I got and also
flashpoint like I said our King said
combat talk will be coming soon on the
ILP channel and a flashpoint 31 is
currently up now with Yvonne Tisch we
breaking down all the ladies stuff in
the economy so for the hardcore
Destiny's means we got you on the iron
law podcast and thanks once again one
last public service announcement now
really close it out because I know we
gotta go is I really thank you guys for
spreading the word it really means a lot
we're trying to bring high quality
content and the new patron subscribers
we really thank you
it really means a lot to us so everybody
please enjoy your Sunday if anybody else
has anything to say if not real close
this thing up
you
[Music]